それではこれから午後の部開催していきたいと思います
どんな段取りになっているのか
私バックヤード見なかったのでわからないんですけど
はい あの午後の部スタートでお願いいたします
[経典] えーと ではよろしくお願いします
あのいろいろあの専業お坊様がね
修行してた専業さんがいろんなプログラムできて考えてるんだからね
それも時間いっぱいやりましょうじゃない
私はしないと思っていたんだけど
全部奪われちゃって [笑い] すいません
脇役の中から脇役に落とされてます
はい では皆様 今日は厳しい環境の中でね
あの 本当に少ない人数で人を選ぶのも大変だからね
まあ皆さんはたくさん方々がそのマッサージに参加していただいているし
まあ基本的なウェーサーカマッスルというのは
まあすごい楽しい気持ちいいマッサージで
それが基本的にそうなるわけですよ
しかし まあまだまだこの感染状態ね
まあウイルスも感染状態もまだいる状態だからね
まあ一応気張りまわることになってしまいました
そういうわけで ここで座ってしゃべると
なかなか今日スタジオを設けてないんですね
で 何か新しい瞑想方法でもね
普段紹介したりはするんだけど
まあこのウェーサーカマッスルを企画立ててる過程で
あまり私は責められ 責められなかったんですね
何か面白いことを考えてくださいとかね
最初からそういうことあったら何か考えちゃいますけど
ですから あの 昨日は冬華さんにどうすればいいかということを聞いたところで
あの 私に対して課題を与えたんですね
で なんで我々に仲良くすることはできないのか
そこでこの仲良くすることをできないと言ったのは
この別寺の皆様のことではなくてね
日本では 日本では仏教あるし
まあ私は別院テーラワーダ上座部仏教のことを紹介してきたりするけど
仏教の宗派という徹底があって
仏教のそういうものはあるんですけど
そこでみんなお互い同じ仏教だから仲良くすればいいでしょうとね
これなんでできないのか
そういうことで なんかいろいろお寺で私の名前を特別に取り上げて敵として仏教を扱われていて
だから なんで でもテレビに出ることは別に嫌いじゃないです
喜んでいるんです [笑い]当たったなと
しかし 仏教はそういう個人的な話ではなくて
もっとすごく広大なもので
だからよし わかりました
それについて再び喋りますと
そこで仏教にとっては宗派が仲良くしなさいと
こんな話はないんです
人間が互いに仲良くしなさいと
だからそれで必死になって
慈悲の生き方 慈悲に基づいた考え方
慈悲に基づいた生活習慣
いろんな方法でお釈迦様が慈悲を語ってるんですね
それは仏教の一部ですよね
全てじゃないんです えーと
まあ事実とはね 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
たったその一行なんですよ
それは生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにというこのフレーズ
自分たちを守る呪文として
最大の守りとして それを実行するならば
人類は問題はないんです
そこで 私がこの慈悲に対してケチをつけちゃうとかなり厳しく攻撃するんです
なぜならば 生きとし生けるもの幸せであります
そんなつまらないことで
あれこれと言ったこと
私はあえて差別と判断するんです
意図的に 人間失格 原始人
石器時代の これ あえてそうやって差別的な言葉考えたり使ったりする
考えて自分で悩んだらすぐ言える
悩むならば相手に言わんでください
俺は一切なくちんけど
なんでそんなに私は慈悲にケチつけちゃうと
差別的なね 意図的に差別的な言葉使いますから
それ間違ってじゃないんです
意図的にですから それぐらい生命
自分を守るためにそれしか心理がないんです
だから一回二回ね 一回はまあ横浜の方に来た時に今日の説法あるわけですね
行って講義したくなったんだけど
まあなかなかあの そこをそこまでできませんでしたけどね
そちらの信者さんのある女性がすごく精神的にいろんな問題抱えていて
だからなんとかなんて言って私たちのところに来たら
私もいろいろ心を落ち着く
慰める方法を教えてあげて
で その方がそれで治りましたからね
自分の精神的な病気が
それであれですわ あの
これと泣いてください
慈悲の瞑想 言ったらまあ私は実は洗礼を受けてますっていうから
よっぽど まあ洗礼を受けてる方にはそれはどうでもいいんだけど
あんた洗礼を受けたってどうでもいいんだけど
このフレーズはどんな宗教にも対立しない
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという言葉が宗教のフレーズじゃないんだ
これ人類が使用しなくてはいけない知恵の言葉
だから言った人のことを忘れちゃえ
言葉がすごいんだ 我々もいろんなフレーズ使ってるでしょ？この漢字でもね
いろんな熟語 フレーズあるでしょ
あれが誰が最初に作ったのかもあんまりわからんね
わからなくても 作者が誰であっても
言葉があまりにも美しいんだったら
人は使うでしょ だから中国で書かれてた四文字句あれこれとのこの漢字で書いているのに
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにっていう
フレーズが 非常に良くわかるんですね
だから聞きたくなるのは
なぜですか？何が悪いですかな
あなた方の信仰に 迷信に
何かが文句言ってるんですか？迷信に凝り固まってる人であっても
修行してないじゃないでしょうか
神を信仰する人も 修行してないじゃないでしょうか
そこで宗教に関係ない若い方々がね
で あ こんなフレーズは嫌でしょうと言うんだけど
その時は若い方々の環境を知ってますからね
くだらない現代人のね
歌えない歌手たちの何か歌のフレーズとかね
それが口ずさんでいる若い方々だから
ちょっと気もいやこれ言うと
私はわかります あんた反対にして唱えてください
それでいいでしょ 生きてしいけないものがしれたのはなんか
言うのは気持ち悪い いいよ
逆に言ってください 十秒で直るんです
だって反対の言葉っていうのは
生きてしいけないものが不幸になりますようにでしょ
でもあるいは私が修行やりますよって
それは気持ち悪いんだ
まあいいよ 私は不幸になりますよって念じてください
気持ち良くない 言った瞬間でパッと意味がわかるんですよ
自分自身が偽善で線に被っていると
私が修行やります こんなこと言ったらあかん
皆の者が修行やりますよと
これは偉いんだ 偽善ですね
だから私が修行やりますよではなくて
私が不幸になりますよと言った時
あれ？気づくでしょ だからそれに気づいてほしいんです
人は幸福になりたいんです
あの牧師にも私が大激へ行かなかったんだけど
すごい過去の話でね 私が会っていた時の
あなたはこのフレーズは神を冒涜することであると
自分が勉強しているキリスト教のどんな学問でもいいんだけど
一つ証拠を出してください
生きてしいけないものが修行やりますよねということは
神を冒涜する言葉であると
のこのこと自分の宗教に逆らったことを言ってるでしょ
右のほっぺたぶん殴ったら左もあげなさいと言ってる教えなのに
だからあの人 服を着て慣れ合ってるんですから
そういう人々は私がその原始原罪だ
野蛮原罪だ だからどうです
まあともあっても 相手が外国人だったら
まあいくらでもエサヘンス
日本語は私にとってはちょっとあまり日本語上手じゃないんだから
あんまり気の利いた言葉が出てこないんです
ですから問題は なんで右のほっぺたり殴ったら左もあげなさいということに逆らって生きているんですか？その
その宗教を信仰している人々
イスラム教でコーランで
人間に何の危害を与えるなと
人間に危害を与えたら
これは神に危害を与えることと同じよと
そこまで言ってるのに
一部の人々はやりたい放題やってるでしょ
なんだこれ そこでキリスト教とイスラム教だけじゃない
我々仏教も同じことでしょう
[鼻をすする]どうやってお互い
お前より俺が偉いってどうやって言えば
言えばいいのかと それしか考えてないんです
ある人々の宗教 宗教組織作ったのは日蓮さんかもしれません
ある人々の宗教を作ったのは道元禅師かもしれません
それそれ師匠がいて 師匠の弟子たちがいて
そこで伝統が現れて 名前もあって
何々宗 何々宗とかね それも普通の自然の流れで
他人を非難侮辱しなさい
他人を貶せ なんでそこまでするんですか
だから何やる 何をやる前に
我々は人間にならなくちゃダメでしょう
それをお釈迦様がおっしゃった膨大なメッセージの中で一つなんです
お釈迦様は人々を自分の宗教に信仰させようとやらなかったんです
仏教の場合は仏教徒になる
仕切りされないんです
何かお寺の中に放り込むと
何か儀式やると 時々あの
韓国の坊さんたちやってるような感じで
あのロウソクで体を燃やしてもらうと
韓国の禅宗の坊さんたちが陸海を受けると
この辺にあなたがロウソクにすりてこの終わるまで全く動かないんですね
耐えって そこで朝があるんですね
そういうのをお釈迦様は何一つ教えてないんです
一回だけでお釈迦様が仏法僧を信仰しなさい
仏法僧 仏教徒になりなさい
膨大な経典ありますよ
面白いことは後で書かれたもっと四倍ぐらいたくさん大乗経典があるんです
そちらにはないんですよ
真理はああだこうだと言ってるだけで
ですからこう思う 人間に根本的な
人間が現れた時からの大きな思考疾患があるんです
人間だけじゃなくて どんな生命も物事を考えると
何かどこかでプログラムがおかしくなっているんです
それでお釈迦様も心理学者みたいな感じか
思考パターンでこちらで問題が起こるんだ
だから思考して決して結論出したら
その結論は決まって間違いない
なぜならば 結論作るこの思考過程に問題があるんです
はい そう言っちゃうと難しくなるんだからシンプルにします
私たちは私という主語を持って考えるんです
私が思う 私は考える 私はこれこれやる
こういう自分という錯覚を前提に入れて考えると
それは自分だけの世界なんです
自分だけの世界は狭くてあまりやばいんです
不安になる だからその人は自分を守りに行かなくてはいけない
そこで私はこう思うと言ったところで
私はこれを信じる 私も私はこれこれこれやと言った途端
自分の敵っていうのは他人になっちゃう
だから敵に対して攻撃してす-潰すか
排他的になるか どちらかになる
だから人間の中にあるいろんな思考システム
全部排他思考なんです
仲間とそうでない人 自分と他人
だからそこは仏教宗派でも他の宗教の宗派でも
何言ってもものすごく排他的なんです
カトリック教的な文化的な信仰がある場合は
プロテスタント的な文化信仰はもう異端で邪道で地獄に落ちる連中なんですよ
それでクリスチャングループがカトリックグループを見ると
あんなのはキリストの教えじゃない
もう間違っていて あんなことしたらもう神を冒涜しているんだから地獄に落ちるんだ
イスラム教の方々はもう唯一の神はアッラーたーらでありし
他の神を信じるのはみんな地獄だ
キリスト教の方々はコーランの通りに祈っても天国にいくのは絶対いないんです
キリスト様の呪願を信仰しなきゃ救われるわけないでしょ
現在 見てみればみんな地獄でしょ
仏教の宗派でもそうでしょう
今失礼ですけど お坊さんたちがいるところでいろいろ宗派の名前を挙げるのは失礼ですけど
まあ律斜宗の座禅の仕方が正しくて
曹洞宗の座禅の仕方が正しくないんです
そうすると悟られるのはやはり臨済宗のしりだりに座禅する人だけ
それで曹洞宗のお寺に顔出してみたら
あんなのはもう意味がない
時間足し合いでしか悟れません
見てみりゃ誰も悟らないで
で 日蓮系の場合はそんなくだらない間違うってる邪言
何年お念仏を唱えたら
それの大宇宙をなんとかなる
そこで見てください 全て思考システムは排他的でしょ
我々が正しいか他は間違っている
スウェーデンの笛岡さんだったとしても仲良くできないものか
こんな人々でできるわけないでしょ
人々というのはすべて地球の生命
我々が正しいというところで
何も成り立ちませんよ
結果は互い喧嘩する 互いにライバルになる
いかにして相手を倒すのか
批判するのか 馬鹿にするのかって考えてるだけ
だからすべてまとめて言えば
人類っていうのは互いに噛みつく生命体なんです
他の生命は自分のグループの中で噛みつくことしないんですよ
地球にいろんな生命がいるでしょ
犬たちがいるし 猿たちがいるし
いろんな種類の鳥たちがいるし
それぞれのグループが互いに殺し合おうではないか
やらないんです 猿の群れは我々は猿だから
では仲間を殺しましょう
噛みつきましょうとは起きない
しかし 猿の一つ猿の群れは別種の猿の群れを見ると相手が敵になる
噛みついて追い出されるか
いて自由を奪われちゃう
いうことになるんです
しかし 一番ひどいのは人間なんです
人間は文化があると言い張る
文明は築いたと言い張る
信仰システムがあると言い張る
政治システムがあると言い張る
科学技術は持ってるんだと言い張る
すべて他を蹴らすために使っているんです
科学技術は人を殺すために使っているんです
そうじゃないと思ってるでしょ
そうじゃない場合もあります
それは金儲かるから使う
金儲かる時でも他人を貧乏にして取り
全部取り上げる これが経済ということなんです
すごい進んでいる すごい進んでいる
我々みたいな坊主たちでさっぱり知らない世界
外から見ると あの連中は仲間をいかに貧乏に陥れるかしか考えてないでしょ
人類が営む経済システム
システムないんです 人類が豊かになる政治システムがないんです
それで昔やったこの えーと
労働者の政治 完璧に嘘でしょあれ
まあそれぞれ名前 コミュニストとか名前あるんだけどもね
それはもう搾取されてるんだと
我々労働者が だから労働者が政権とればいいじゃないかと
そこで搾取消えますよ
消えたんですか？何人かが人
動物扱いされているんです
中国でもロシアが今共産主義じゃないんだけど
ロシアでも北朝鮮でも国民はもう獣です
一部の何人かだけ 神に成り上がった
あの死んだ人間の遺体は今でもあるでしょ
拝むんです マオツェツンの遺体はまだ拝んでるでしょ
結局は神に成り上がってるんじゃないですか
金日成の 金日成の保管して拝んでるでしょ
人間はけしからぬ 人間には何一つ立派なことできないんです
人を差別すること 人を汚すこと
これが進化する道やというんです
それ違うと言ったら世界一徹底した
私はブッダ殿よりも悪人ですね
日本の坊さんたちを私に名前挙げて
あいつはもうとんでもないって
勉強会開いてみてください
どんなに言う気なくなる
だから私は時々すごい汚い単語ですけどね
誰も私にかなわないように
すごい汚い単語ですよ
でも使います 秘密があります
私は生命平等だと 平等だと思ってるんです
それが誰にも壊すことできない
壊そうとする人が壊されるだけ
その真理をもっと素朴
もっと敏感なく言うんです
かなわないこととかって
だから汚く言った方が皆さんは
あ そうですかって聞いてくれるんです
美しく言ったら馬鹿にされるだけでしょう
馬鹿にされるのたまらないんだから
ああいう風に言うんです
だから私は別に大したことない
皆様と同じですけどね
でも生命は平等だと思ってる
そこは違うところなんです
だから仲良くできないのは
人間のこの自我中心的な思考なんです
自我中心で考えたら その瞬間からすべて汚れた臭い考えなんです
すべて恐ろしい細菌の流れ
だから我々は いろんな哲学者からいろんな師匠たちが自分の思考を世に発表するでしょう
そのたびに細菌ばらまいてるような感じなんです
だから世は一番逆らいたがる
反対したがる教えはブッダの純教え
そこにブッダの教えにとっていろいろ宗派で
そ-祖師様たちの教えを作って
それを拝んでいる そちらのほうは攻撃はそれほどないんです
だってもう一つゴミだからね
ゴミ ゴミ ゴミ ゴミ ゴミがこれで
あ このゴミは汚いと まあ言えないでしょうね
そこで我々は自分が他人と違う
自分が他人より優れている
自分の方がかっこいい
かっこいい 自分の方が正しい
いうためにあらゆる方法を使います
あらゆる 一つは仏教のことを我々仲間のことを喋りましょう
うちの師匠大宗様がもう千年前
二百年前で割れて 法要を指導していて
我々は今千年もこの伝統で守っている
伝統を守っているんだ
怒ってるんです 中国のなんだかんだが
人が法流に分かれて その伝統で
だから何か自分の宗派の歴史が四百年あったら
それで俺が偉い 他が偉くないということにしたわけです
和装 衣も同じですけど
日本の分では衣の着方
形 それでお互いに怒り合っているんです
どちらが正しいのか だから伝統を守ることはそんなに悪いことじゃないんだけど
だからといってそれによって他人がへこますことは不可能です
日本で一般的にはキリスト教はすごく偉いと思ってるんですね
だけど勉強してないんです
なぜあれほど偉いと思ってる？鉄砲持ってきたからですね
キリスト教はアジアに何もあげたけど鉄砲あげたんです
それでお互い殺し合いやっていたでしょ
異常によって あるいはあれでなんて言われた
その時に これやばいんでしょ
侍がやっちゃうとどちらかが死ななくちゃあかんでしょ
だから五分五分なんですね
まあまあ鉄砲あれば一方的に勝てるんですね
だから一番腰のやり方でしょ
機関銃でバチバチ撃つことは
昔侍たちはそうじゃなくて
お互い大判見せてね 戦ったんだけど
しかし それでも相手を殺すっていう考えです
これはより技術のより上位の人だと殺されるんだから
鉄砲持ってきた野蛮人を怒ることになっちゃうんです
だから野蛮なのは中国人もヨーロッパ人もアジア人も日本人もみんな俺らに野蛮人ですよ
自分の国の南アジアの連中も朝からガンバですから
でもどうやって俺が偉い相手が偉くないと立証しようではないか
そこで民主主義っていう政治
政治システムあるでしょ
民主主義なんてかっこいいね
なんで？皆民主主義ですから
どんな国が民主主義 民衆の民のみんなの意見を通って政治やってますか？そういう国がある？どこかに
そこで民主主義の政権がせー election
選挙  選挙 行わなくちゃいかんでしょ
それで政党が必要でしょ
政党って何？うちの政党は正しい
愛してるですから 同じこっちゃでしょ
それで民主主義政権では野党と与党二ついるんです
野党はお前らが間違ってる
与党はお前らが間違ってる
見てみりゃ両方間違ってるでしょ
迷惑よ 人類に だからそういう風に哲学を批判しても
宗教批判しても 文化を批判しても
この問題は消えません
だからお釈迦様がチェクチな心
チェックして自分が作ってる壁を全部破ってみてください
空きの人間になってください
どこかに閉じ込められたちっちゃなこう
小さな浅かな空気の一滴ではなくて
大気に溶けてみてください
全て消えますよ 問題は
争いは 悩み苦しみも だからそれがあらゆる言葉で
あらゆる制限で同じことが起こるんです
自我をなくせとかね 私は姿の我
自我の錯覚 イリュージョン
イリュージョンなくせ
イリュージョンをなくしてみてください
だから我はいるという実感ある限り
人間で仲良くすることはできないんです
それから 生が全て平等で
自我が成り立たないと知っているブッダにとっては
まあ人間というのはもう相手にならんね
だからお釈迦様出てきてください
それから自分の意見に自分の考えに
それ元々間違ってるでしょ
愛着が起こる 起こるんです
愛着は 自分が何か美しいと思ったら
これ自分の感覚でしょ
それで愛着が起こるんです
そうするとそれは美しくないよと誰かが言うと腹が立つんです
その人は私には美しいんだけど
この人には美しく見えないね
と理解することはできない
かなり昔 私はある子供
ちっちゃな子供と 今日何やりたいのかと言って
何か映画の名前言って
この映画見たい で 私はもう大人で
僕の面倒見てるから もう連れてって映画見せたい
じゃあ見せてあげようかなと思ってたんです
思っていたんだけど いきなりはい
行きましょうと言う子供の奴隷になりたくないんだから
あの映画でしょ？ねー
あれって恐ろしい映画
まあ子供が好きになってる映画だからね
あんな変な悪いやつ出てくるけど
なんだろう できるだけ批判して
批判したらこの子供が貢献できなくて
仕方なく でも五十分ですけど
[笑い]これその子の言葉一緒であったんです
でも俺は好きですと そこで私は大人として子供に何か教えたいです
慈悲心を 子供がそのうちわかったんです
俺は好きですけど 好きじゃない人間もいるんだと
それで俺が好きなんですけど
自分で幕を見てくるよとかね
はい わかった じゃあ一緒に行こう言って
あの映画見よう 行って映画館探して
二人で計画立てて どんな電車に乗ってどこに降りればいいかなとかね
計画立てながら行ってその映画を見たんですね
映画見て子供はもう大興奮
もうお帰りできない 親父は「私にはつまんなかった
苦手な愛情シーン」といったことを私に心配して
あの興奮してギャーギャーギャーギャーしゃべることに余裕があったんです
ですから あの そういう風に世間では子供たちに教えますよね
一生懸命我は思う故に我は存在す
例えば別の例出してみましょう
仏教では嘘をついてはいけないと言ってますね
キリスト教では嘘をつきなさいと言ってますかね？いつでもそういう風に言ってる？言ってないです
キリスト教でも嘘をついてはあかんぜと言ってるし
仏教も嘘をついてはあかんぜと言ってるし
だから同じじゃん それは人間考えることでしょう
同じじゃないんです あれはキリスト教の教えに従って嘘をついてはいけないと
そちらに結論に達した過程があるんです
ある個人が考えた過程があるんです
仏教で嘘をついてはあかんと言ったら
それは私が言ってるんじゃなくて
ブッダの言葉だから ブッダは嘘をなぜついてはいけないのかと考えた過程がある
だから嘘をつくなかれというフレーズだけを見て
みんな同じこと言ってることにならないんです
もしそうなるなら より宗教争いは消えなきゃならないです
こうしてまとめて言ってるではないか
嘘をついてはあかんと言ってるではないか
優しい人間になれと言ってる
言ってるではないか 他を違う誰かと
だったら宗教は仲良くすればいいでしょ
仲良くはしませんよ できるだけ相手を潰したいんです
それでしょ だから宗教世界もいかにして相手を潰すのかと考えてるんだから
その人々の指導で生活する一般人のことはもう呼ぶわけないでしょう
真理はそんな馬鹿げた話ではないんです
だから仏教は真理を語ったんです
ブッダは本当のところ嘘をつくなかれと言っていないです
盗むなかれと言っていないです
勘違いしないでおください
ブッダ教えているのは
まあこういうこういう結果になるからよ
まあ提案として嘘をつかない方がよろしい
嘘をつくか つかないか
それはその人の自由です
あらゆる膨大な道徳 膨大な心理
修行法 あらゆる聖人に語っているのに
真理というのはこうします
自分で判断してください
ですから もし人類 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにとことが生き方である
それだけで世界は治ります
全部病気 各思想システムの互いのライバル意識がなくなり
大学同士でもお互いライバル意識でしょ
皆さんは知ってるでしょ
もう私はもうもうそろそろ死にますから
別にもう大学生に関係ないんだけど
同じ学問であっても それぞれ大学の教授たちは相手を敵視しているんです
真理は何かと関連することじゃなくて
あの考えどうやって破壊つぶれるのか
だから学者の世界でもいろんな学派
いろんな考えあるんだけど
それも他を非難侮辱するために使われるんです
この人々を理解してもらわないのは
例えばソウショロジー学ぶ
ソウショロジーって何ですか？ 社会学
社会学 全ての社会学を学べないんだから
自分自分いろいろ参考にとっていろいろ研究する
それでたくさん意見は投げたそうだよ
それだけ言っておけば
かなり昔 私はあるお寺に
あの 禅寺だと思いますけど
何かのテーマあって喋っていたんですよ
私に頼んだテーマだから
テーマの中 テーマの中でずっと時間ちょっともすぎてしゃべりてしゃべりてしゃべったんです
あれは領収のお坊さんたちもいろいろ話聞いていたわけですね
私はこの人を喧嘩するアイデアはもうほとんど言わないよ
あえて言う場合は ちょっとユーモア取るために言うだけ
笑ってもらうためにけなってるんです
別に心の中で何も思ってないんです
今日も結構詮議されたりいろいろ言いやったりしたんだけど
全然喧嘩するつもりじゃなくて
俺だから笑って気持ちよく言おうではないか
ですから まあそういう人が気持ち悪くなる言葉はできるだけ言っちゃいますけど
そこでずっとその話を聞いて
お坊さんも聞いていて
でもあのお坊さんが自分がまあ相当そういうのお寺ですから
なんかどこまで自分の立ち場が壊れたと思っちゃったみたいです
かわいそう そこでみんなお互いの意見言ったり質問したりするけど
そのお坊さんが 「ああ
菅沼猿人はいろいろことをたくさん喋りましたけど
空のことは喋れなかった」と 「
こちらではもう空の教えです」と言ったんですね
私は黙っていたんです
もう知ってるんだから
このバカが あのアホが二つの点で間違ったんです
一 私は空について知ってるか知らないのか
私に聞いて 自分の固定概念で
まあどうせテーラワーダ上座仏教だからね
空の思想知るわけないでしょっていう固定概念
もう一つの問題は テーマに関係ないんです
当たり前に だからテーマに関係ないし
私は空思想知ってるか調べていないし
それで空のこと喋れなかったんだから
私の話がレベル低いと言ったところに
もし私が反論したらどうなるんですか
純職に当りはる でもそんなことはやらんだから
まあ黙ってしまいました
ということにしたんです
ですから この知識人はよろしいし
哲学者もよろしいし まあいろんな人間が考えるものだから
完璧じゃないんです 何一つ
だから我々言ってること
やってることを 考えてること
何一人しも完璧じゃないから
もうちょっと落ち着きます
日本人には日本人として誇りあるかもしれませんだけど
誇りを持つ必要ないでしょ
あんた計画立てて日本人になったんですか？選んだんですかね？世界の民族の中で日本という日本人の民族が唯一優れてる
だから私は日本人になって
我々とか 振り返ってみたら
なんか誰かお前日本人やと言われただけの話でしょ
我々の場合そうなんです
私もこう思ってることは
自分生まれた民族を捨てることもできる
いたって単純にできる
やっちゃったんだもん
それはただの人間がやっただけです
まあ文化的にいろいろあんたの祖先なんですからということで
それはもう世間のものにはならない
というわけで この仲裁するということは
こんなシンプルで歌っただけで成り立つものじゃないんです
それは智慧の世界 智慧を開発しなくちゃあかんのです
全て無常や 自分も無常や
自分というものはないんだと
だから今日ちょっと瞑想を紹介することできなかったんだから
ほんのちょっと触れてみます
皆様は自分の体が構成している部品を
臓器のリストを作ってみてください
これ仏教ではリストありますけど
それ使っても古いリストだから
現代のちょっとしたこの子供たちのそういう関係の本を開けてみたら
髪の毛であるとかあって
骨があって あれやこれとかね
腎臓 心臓あれこれとあるでしょ
このリスト全部取ってみてください
スネもあるしね スネだっても足のスネと指のスネがそれぞれ違うし
指にだっても五本指あるし
それぞれそれ違う名前あるでしょ
いくつかの臓器はペアで
ペアでない臓器がありますね
それは何ですか？まあ
皆さんも知りたいからね
答え まあ胃袋 大腸とかね
小腸 心臓 まあペアじゃないです
肺はペアですね 脳はペアです
ですから左と右っていうふうに分かれますね
それをリストにとって
いちいちチェックしてみます
はい 髪の毛 一 髪の毛 私ですか？髪の毛が私ですか？いいえですね
答えは？答え あ 髪の毛ないね
[笑い]髪の毛が私ですか？いいえ
正解は？正解したら もうやるの私が
私ではありません 私ではありません
だからそれ言ったでしょ
それが正解 それが正解で
私の髪の毛 私の髪の毛
そうそう 私の髪の毛です
はい 左目 私ですか？違います
私の左の目です 右のペアですからね
髪の毛は ろくに見えないのに世界は
目が二つある ちょっとこれ不公平ですよ
目を二つ持ってろくに何も分からない
目が二つあるのに 余は見ていない
世を見ていない 耳が二ついてるのに聞いてない
それは冗談で では右目が私ですか？バツ
違います 私の右目です
そこで自分の体を構成するリストは
例えば三百あっても 千五百あっても
一万あっても同じ答えですよ
私ではないでしょ 私の髪の毛
ダラダラダラダラダラダラでしょ
私の脳みそでしょ じゃあ逆にfunctionに移ってみましょうか
思考が私ですか？妄想が私ですか？体のfunction見ても
機能を見ても 歩くことが私ですか？寝ることが私ですか？食べる行為が私ですか？悩みが私ですか？落ち込みが私ですか？どう聞いても答えは違います
悩みが私ではなくて 私の悩み
処方で跡形もなく消えるでしょ
私ってどこにあるんですか？では全てマテリアル私ですか？いいえ
そういう意味 はい これではなく別な私がいるんですか？ないんです
私の体が空き家であって
私が空き家になるわけないでしょ
ですから それも一つの瞑想なんです
こういう瞑想というのは
お釈迦様は歴々たる場合は提唱の方法で
お釈迦様じーっと質問します
そこで主義として 事実として
あんた見つからない 誰に？ね
シュリちゃんについて
することは大聖人ですよ
大聖人 だったら知ってなさい
で そういうことで あの
私たちは存在すらしない
どこかで で 便利で 考えるときに便利な単語ですから
この単語に執着してる
要は生き地獄にしてる
生きることが地獄になっているのは過去に積もる私という実感があるから
何もないんだったら困ることは何もないでしょ
私がいなかったら別にいいけど
物体があって まあそれが痛くなったりしても別にいいじゃないでしょう
私がいなかったら誰かがまあガチャガチャガチャガチャ悪いこと言っちゃっても
私がいなかったらどう？なんか言葉流れてるだけ
人があんたほど邪険邪道の人はいませんと言っても
私は私が誰に？誰のことを言ってた？だからそこで判断自由っていうのは目の前で現れるんです
まあもう一つワンポイント言って話終了します
世の中みんな平和好きですね
人類みんな平和が好きだったら世界は平和でしょ
平和大反対という人がいる？いない
変でしょ 私じゃ平和大反対
私は戦争は正しいと思っているという人間はいない
なのに相互消滅論ですから
ひと欠片の平和がないでしょ
過去も現在も おそらく将来も
これで変でしょ 理解できます？これを解決するポイントは本来は私が他人ではない
だから自分をそこで平和が好きだったら
自分は攻撃受けないことだけ考える
攻撃を受けて受けたら徹底的にやってる
ですから どこかであの自我の錯覚がちょっとちょっと気づいたら
そこで至って単純に戦争の偉大が現れてます
するんです もともと錯覚なんです
そこで調和 という単語をね
よく日本でもいろいろよく聞こえますね
ということは 一欠片もないです
皆様方 調和 ないから皆様方調和を楽しむためにハチャメチャ行動する
お辞儀するわ 言葉気をつけるわ
もう結婚式でこんな言葉
友達だったらこんな言葉とかね
あるわあるわ 使ってはならない単語
使ってならないだけ何かあるんです
だから一欠片も調和がないから
この社会で皆様方が調和を楽しむために四苦八苦しているんです
結果が調和がないんです
どう見ても相手が何か悪いということなんです
仲良くさせることすっげえ難しい
だから私はなんか世に何か今この考え方入ってるからと
言った途端にやべえってして思うんですよ
まあやべえ 例えばどうとこうなどうでも誰かもう喉の血が出るまで喋ってるならば
やばい その人は調和やし
だから一般的なあんまり道徳的なこと大概言う人のこと嫌いでしょう
普通です やばいです 親和的に我々はこの平和の哲学
調和の哲学 仲良くするための哲学はものすごくたくさんあるんですね
ということは一つもないから
あるものにすると 誰も喋ったり哲学をしたりはしない
だから一つ例えが 例え出します
私たちは一人一人皆様も
私は人間であるということは立証するために
証明するために苦労する
いろんな証拠を 証 資料を集めてファイル作って携帯に入れて
引き取り出す こういうことで
こういうことで 私は人間です
いらねえ なんで 人間だから
あるいは人間なら二種類いるでしょ
男と女っていうの まあたまに例外ありますけど
まあ例外置いておいて
普通の場合は自分が女であり
自分が男であるというために
ハチャメチャ立証する文章持ってくる必要ありません
議論する必要ありません
ないでしょ まあたまに疑われるケースありますよ
でもそれは一般的に皆さん知ってるんだから
どうしても必要だったら聞いてみれば
そういう人 聞かなくてもなんか時々日本でいますよ
ものの見事に女装する男性がいるんです
どう見てもバレない なぜならばそれでバレない
女は女が演じないんです
女はだらしないんです
あんまりにも正確に歩く時に
座る時に 手上げるときとかね
あんまりにも完璧だから
これはもう男です あの
日本で あの 女役やる舞台あるでしょ
あれやってた  玉三郎 歌舞伎
歌舞伎  歌舞伎で出てくる女どうでしたね
あれの女たち可愛いなと思うでしょ
でもあれ男ですよ ぶっ通し男です
だから何か完璧で演じるならば
中身は反対っていうことでしょ
だから女は女の恩人が
ってやると気をつけて女々しくてやりたいらしいから
もういいから 気が ですから
世に道徳的な話があれもあるわね
一つも道徳じゃない 平和のためにか
そうそうよ あれ 人類をみんな神が創ったという
その時点でやばい おかしい
だったら シュッと要らんでしょ
それでも人間は神が創ったなら
なんで神は綺麗事ですよ
だからあなたは神を信じなさい
なんで信じるの？ なに？いや
あんたは神を知らんから
え だからって神のこと知らんように創ったのかね？でしょ
だから神を信じることは神の粋に
何する？神様 私に幸福を与えてください
俺 祈ってない これは強盗になる
もし私が不幸だったら
私は不幸を感じてるならば
全知全能の神がそういうふうにセッティングしてるんだと
だから何があってもありがてえと言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
ウクライナ人がありがたいと死んだ方がいいんです
なんてありがたいんですか？決して悪いでしょ
ロシア人もロシアの貧しい人々は戦場に出されて殺って殺されてるでしょ
殺すだけありがたい ありがたいロシア人
言って死んだ方がいいんじゃない？人間何言うのかい
だからたとえ妄想して全知全能の神が俺を創ったって
これも排他的な結果になるんです
他を被弾物とするために使う
永遠の天国 永遠の地獄と創って
それで人を被弾物にすることです
差別を駆り立てる なんでそんなに頑張って差別を駆り立てるんですかね
我々はあなたと違う だけど日本人はアメリカ人と違いますよ
日本人はヨーロッパ人と違いますよ
聞いてないんだけど いっぱいいるでしょ
日本人は中国人と違いますよ
自分のことを教えたがるんですよ
我々日本 韓国人と日本人というのは
一緒と間違う 我々の目からはその区別できないんです
だから最初に大輪として会った人は何人か見たら
ああ これと言ったら もう一人
二人 はい これと言っても
みんなすごく「Yes」って
あんちゃんいい人 [笑い]面白いこと書くところあるんです
百人の場合はある程度慣れてますから
そう失言しないんです
無理 無理と言われると聞くんです
で 別に私はどうなんでしょう
本日の例の  何？名前見た感じじゃないね
[笑い]そこで自分のことを誇示して言わなきゃいけなくなっちゃうわけですね
そこで なんで私はこういうもの
こういうもの あんたたちと違いますよ
そんなこと言いたがってる
日本の調和の話と同じ
和合の話と同じ うるさいほどみんな和合の話してる
なんであんな和合なんだ
調和なんだ 人間それほど自分が違うかと
あっぱれにも頑張って苦労するのは
もともとみんな平等だからなんです
だから人間は 我々は人間であることを証明することは一切しないんです
女は 私は女であることを立証して証明するために一切何もしない
そこはすっごい楽ちんでる
しかし 自分が他人と違うと言うために
どれほど苦しんでるかという
それで我々仏教のやり方は
だから言っただろう みんな平等だと
だから嘘を立証するためにものすごい苦労しなくちゃ
裁判で嘘の表現すると
それは証言が嘘でないように
ばれないようにするためにはものすごい難しいんですよ
だから簡単に生命は平等だと言わせてもらいます
これで楽ちんです それで問題は解決です
その時点に来ない限りは
仏教の宗派の間もお互いに牙をむいて噛みつこうとしている
キリスト教のたくさん宗派があるんだからね
仏教のお坊さんで負けてますよ
頑張ってくださいね [笑い]たくさん宗派が
キリスト教に負けんなよ
[笑い]テーラワーダ仏教派でいっぱいあるんです
どちらもまあいろいろ
[笑い]だけど他の宗派が引っ張っていかないしと言うために
宗派なんですよ はい そういうことで
これブッダのメッセージで真実
事実 本当のことです 生命は平等です
たとえ邪見違う それぞれの生命は自分に適した生き方してるだけ
そこは良いでも悪いでもなくて
そのものなんです ウサギは人参食べる
猫は食べない どちらが偉い？どちらをけなす？バカでしょう
ウサギって猫たい思ってるんだから人参食べる
猫って猫たい思ってる生命が
もう何たかですね わからない
チーズ食べてる ウサギが悪くもないし
チーズ食べてる猫があんた菜食主義じゃないねとかね
けなすこともできないです
人間それはやってるでしょ
私は菜食主義や 私は食べません
そういうことでしょう
だから菜食主義者が自分が菜食主義であることで威張ろうとしてるんでしょ
もしくは自負ってああいう連中はものすごく肉魚好きだと思う
[笑い]だから自分をいじめて苦しんでとにかく俺が偉いと
ではなぜ先生は肉が嫌いも食べられないという人は
それでもって人をけなすこともしないし
自分がちょっと上ってことしないんですね
だから食い物からでも私たちはお互いに
喧嘩しようとしてる 私
日本に来て最初の頃 我々学生グループでいたんだから
かなりいたずらグループなんですよ
そんな年齢でもなかったけど
結構外国からちょろっと聞いたんだから
だからまあ結構いるんだ
いたずらするの そこで時々日本人があんた方はどこで聞いたかてご飯食べることを言っちゃうと
我々はあれってすごく気持ち悪くなる
我々は箸を使って 我々手で食べます
というと 人間の頭の中に手で食うよって食べてるなんかヤバい人のイメージが現れるんです
これ感じてお互い笑っちゃう
やられたけどわからないんです
最初はそういう楽しみがあったんだけどね
そりゃ同じ空間に入っちゃうと
どうせあの人と同じ人の列に並ぶことしかできませんだけど
だから手で食べることは品格がないとか
箸で食べることは品格がいいとか
なんだこれ 箸で食べる時のそれなりのしりたり文化がある
ナイフフォークを使う場合もそれなりのしりたり文化がある
手で食べる時でもありますよ
ちっちゃい時からそういうのは学んでわからない
だから私たちから見れば
日本の方々はじゃあみんな一緒だから私みたいに食べましょうと
だから我々はそうと言うんだけど
本当は手で食べてほしくないんです
なぜならば我々は品格と思うものは全部終わってるんです
しょうがないんでしょうね
知らないから かえって一緒に仲間だから仲良くなろうって努力してるんだから
そこら辺は評価してあげるんです
だから人間っていうのは仲良くできんね
食い物からでも等しさですよ
ブッダの答えは生命は平等です
ウサギという形だったら人間食べる
猫という形になっちゃうと
こいつはどう頑張っても最初の順位にならない
いくら有機栽培で育てた草を持ってきても
犬は食べない しかし このリミット超えてすぐ生命平等だとは
じゃあ最終的にちょっと面白いエピソード
面白いけど私だけが楽しい
皆様にも面白いと思わなくてもいいんですよ
ただ 猫はたまたま草食べるんですよ
なんか理由があってよくわからない
でも食べる草の種類があるんです
今ペットショップで売ってるんだけどね
あれってあんまり猫が面白がらないんです
ちょっと闇に入って いろんな雑草の中から自分の薬になる草を探してるんですね
それで話を聞くと 時々ある猫がそれやって
やむなく探し求めて見つかる
で 私は上から見るんだから見つけてね
見つけて食べる葉っぱ見つけてるんです
だから呼んでこれでしょ
それでこれでしょ 行ったらそれ
ああそうだ それ食べて食べて
だから猫が何を探しているのか知ることで
どんな草食べてるのか知ることできる
草の中のどんな葉っぱも無差別に食べない
その葉っぱにも位置 形いろいろあるんです
それは猫の本能で知ってるんです
薬になるのはこの葉っぱで
これじゃない だから この我は違うという気持ち捨てちゃうと
偉くなったりすることできますよ
すごくいい世界があるわけです
はい これのテーマはそれで終了です
えーと 我々は自覚している感覚で全部間違ってるんだってね
人間という生命は考えて行動する生命なんです
だから人間だけ必ず間違えるんです
まさしく考え方がおかしいんです
私という職場で考えるから
だから職を与えるということは
動物の世界では起きませんね
人間の世界で起こります
思考しているから 食べ物を見て
これは体 自分の体に悪いと判断できるんです
はい そういうことで 仲良くするということも一つの高度なことで
仏道の道で神霊を発見する人が仲良くするんです
神霊を発見しない限り
生命は我は正しい 相手は間違っているというすごい苦しみの世界で生きるんです
ウェーサーカの法を得て
ブッダのメッセージを得て
それを受け取ってください
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
引き続きまして 我々大乗側からの
我々 我々って使ったらいけないんでしたね
仲間の仲間のうちの一員の大乗側からのご案内会ということになります
よろしくお願いいたします
それで今日は大乗のお坊さん
たくさんのお坊さんがいらっしゃってますので
皆さん会場の皆様にいろいろご質問出していただきまして
全体的な仏教の我々 本当に良い兄と悪い弟
すいません皆さん 悪い弟じゃない
出来の悪い弟 そんな関係ですのでね
ほんと大乗仏教への質問でも大丈夫ですし
テーラワーダ仏教に関する質問でも大丈夫ですよね
皆さんね これ自信があるようなお顔をしていただいているので大丈夫だと思います
そういうわけであの 今日何かご質問等ありましたら
どんどんお受けして 我々基本的には大乗仏教側からお答えして
もしあまりにも難しかったら
ちょっと割込みます 割込みます
えーとですね 日本の皆様方
あんまりこのお坊さんたちと仲良く喋ることをしないんですね
だから私はこのチャンス
皆様がおっしゃりたいでしょうね
だから普通に質問投げてではなくて
普通に仲良く喋って お互いに教え合いあって
そういう グッドコミュニケーションね
作ってくださいと いう感じで今日を過ごしようかなと思っております
はい どうぞ  はい すいません
受け取りました こちらからいただきます
また すぐ私 ジャイナ教長老のお寺に昔お邪魔した時に金にけてた方ですよね
ちょっと叱っちゃってすみません
嘘を言ってすみません
今野先生 壇蜜社長がね
彼めちゃくちゃ音上手なんですよ
だからもうしょっちゅう伺って
よくご馳走してもらって
この肉の三分の一は壇蜜社長の肉で出来上がったものですね
それでは何かのお話とか
大乗仏教の それでこちらがあの
緒方さんという尼僧さんでいらっしゃいますね
つ つち つ 元土屋ですか
うまく言えませんが 元土屋さんの尼僧さんで
えっと 綺麗だからといって手触ったりしないでくださいね
今ソーシャルディスタンスでうるさくやってますから
手 手 手握ったりしないように
ちょっとマイクの上手に引き渡ししてください
向こうにいらっしゃるのが穂坂君といってね
総統のお坊さんなんですけど
まあ若くて まあこの我々の中で一番若くてかっこいいお坊さんということで
あの綺麗な女性の尼僧さんとかっこいいお坊さんということでね
皆さん手触ったりかもしれませんけど
お坊さんの方もあまり触ら
握ったりしない ちょっとぐらいだったらいいですけどね
よろしくお願いします
で 自分でお願いします
どうぞ  あ あのー 二回思ってたことあったんですけど
うちの ちょっと話しても
もうすぐですよ  あの うちの檀家っていうか
お寺さんは浄土宗なんです
でも あの うちの父があの
何て言うの 大工をやってましたので
あの もう三十 亡くなって三十年経って
こう 父のものの中から経典が出てきたんですね
その経典がその父母恩寵経
父母 聞いたことあります？ 父母恩寵経でしたっけ
恩寵経それがあるんですけど
それが  父母 父母恩寵経
父母  父母 父母  えっとね
父母って  大丈夫です  えーと
二だから 父母 父母恩寵経があって
うちの祖母も父もそれを持っていて
あの その影響もあって
あの なんていうのか マリア像とかの
キリスト教でもそういうのがあったんで
こう受け入れてくれたんですけど
その父母恩寵経というのは
その あの 何て言うのかな
あそこ 経典の中には古い経典があって
ずっと日本のとか北米のところから来たのとか
あの どういうものなのか教えていただきたいと
私とテリーが追いかけます
我々大乗仏教の一番しっかりしている先生
大先生 冬岡泰典先生にお伺いしてもよろしいでしょうか
いいと思ってくださったらいいと思います
はい えーと 私はそういう研究というか
学問的にあまり深くこの音はどういう成り立ちでということはあまり知らないものなんです
で 自分の宗派で普段使っているお経を読んだりするということはやっておる
その中にもやっぱりその父母恩寵経というのは使っているお寺もあったりして
私のところではそういうことはしたことがなかったんですけど
まあそれにはやっぱりいろいろな優しい心を持つ
持たせる意味の文章ですのでね
そういうものを読んで気持ちを落ち着くというか
そういうふうに使っておられるお寺もあるし
その 感じで これはいい言葉だなと思われて使っている言葉だと思います
それでどういうことなんですかね
職域競技とは  関係 関係
関係とか   職業との関係は
私の場合はそれこそ日本の宗派というのは
やっぱり常盤先生のご講演のように
みんなそれぞれ自分の宗派
宗派というのが一番正しいものでということでやらなくちゃ
自分のやってるより隣の宗派のお寺の方が正しいよと思ってたら
そっちをやらなくちゃおかしいわけですから
みんなそういうことで
自分たちのやっているやり方
使っているお経本 そういうやり方でやっている
でもそれは随分違うんだから
そこでお互いにこちらが正しいというふうにやりかけると
えらいことになるんですね
だからそこは私なりの考えでは
やっぱりそれは自分たちはそういうふうにこれが大事だと思っているし
隣の宗派の他の方々もそういうふうに思っているんだから
それはそれで尊重というか
大事にしながらいればいいのではないかと思います
非常に良い経典だったので
随分前から読んで 読んだ
読んでたんですが テーラワーダ仏教にはあるとかないとか
そういう点を知りたいです
テーラワーダ仏教の中では
特にそのような形ではないと思いますが
日本文化の中で出来上がった経典ということで
文化というか 中国からずっと伝わってくる中にそういうものが混ぜている
中国からこう来たあれってことですね
ですから それが大事だなと思って読まれるのはすごく良いこと
それはそれで置いておいて
あの お釈迦様は本当に元々おっしゃられたお経っていうのが
それこそ日本には明治を過ぎてから
明治の時代にそういうものが伝わってきたということのようなんですね
だからそのいつも教会のそういうものを読まれたことはありません
それの中のお経のお釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
そのまま読んでみたら
もうそれは大変なことなんです
だからそれはそれとして
それはそれで はい わかりました
ありがとうございます
はい ありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
それはそれとこれはこれっていう感じでね
でもあのお父さんお母さんを大切にするっていうことは
もうめちゃめちゃ大切なことでしてね
我々なんていうんですね
我々のこの体はね もう 1 ミリグラムも何も持ってきて生まれてませんからね
お父さんお母ちゃんから借りたね
だけ お父ちゃんお母ちゃんはこの体の特許を持ってるっていう感じですよね
だからこの体を使ってね
お父ちゃんお母ちゃんの幸せを祈るっていいますか
元気で我々もね 元気で明るく過ごすことが
この特許を持ってる両親への感謝の表し方かなと
そんな風に常々思っておりますね
だからこれからもブッダの御教典を大切に読んでいただけたらと思います
はい ありがとうございます
他に何か じゃあこの人か
若い子の方がね 会場にもまだ走れるから
スマナサーラ長老にお聞きしたいことがあるんですけれども
よろしいでしょうか  ダメです
私に聞いてください  経典で読んだこの世は苦行みたいなことがいっぱいあるっていう
生きることが苦であるみたいな感じの仏教の教えで
その中でも仏教ではこの世の人々を永久的に幸せにする導いてくれる幸せの方法があるみたいな感じのところを読んだんですけど
私も一応ちょっとインスタグラムでやったりとかしてるんですけど
人々が永久的に幸せになる方法って具体的に実践していくには何をやっていけばいいんですか？ ああ
そうね それは今日先ほど長老がお話しくださった生きとし生けるものが幸せになりますように
でもまず まずさ まず自分が幸せでありますようにと思わないと
私は常に幸せだと思ってるんですけど
精神病にちょっと冒されて発作が出たと
死のうとずっと自殺したいと思うような状態
そういう抑うつ病もなくなって
飲食時に困っちゃったらどうしようとか常に不安になってるんですよね
そうね 誰でも不安になるんだけど
この不安って何で起こるかって言ったら
今ちょうど先ほどのお話の通り
私がいるっていう気持ちから不安が起こるの
いろいろ調べながらとかも生きてるとそれが逃れたいんですけど
どうすればいいですか？ 逃れたい
逃れる 私 こんな一人で喋って平気です
ちょっと待って 貴子さん呼ぶから
こんにちは 私は松岡と言います
ああ そうですか  あの Instagram やってるのでよかったら見てみてください
ありがとうございます
ここ ここで宣伝しない方がいいと思います
ごめんなさい  まあでも
どんな大きなことでも小さなことでも関わり合って支え合っているので
自分の中で辛いことだったら
別にそれに勝とうなどと思わないでね
逃げればいいし  でも逃げてたら
大丈夫  長引いて長引いてつらいって
全然全然  悪魔とかの依頼になってっちゃう
いやもう そ そ そ あ 悪魔が出てくると大変なんで
そういうことなんです
私 七月三十日生まれの今年で三十九なんですけど
そういうあの 霊障みたいな感じで
うーん まあとにかくいろんな人がいるからね
あの うーん 誰でもその人の意見を聞いたりとかする必要はないけれども
とにかく自分を大切にして
そして  優しい言葉だったり
まあ優しい言葉よりかちょっと気をつけた方がいいですけど
だけど あの 自分を大切にしてね
付き合っていくというか
それはいいと思います
だから あの 何かがもう本当にこう
つらいなとかって思うとね
まずね やっぱりこう 少し休まないといけないね
頑張るよりかね  映画と仕事が始まったんですけど
そうなんですか  私一応芸術家の座長なんですよ
それも自分の中でとっても素敵だなと思うことがあったら
やっぱそれ それも大切なことなので
まあとにかく頑張って修行しようとかね
でも修行したいっていうのは
やっぱり小学校の頃に仏教の漫画とか読んでたら
ずっと心から もう体質的にそんな感じなんです
そうなんですか まあでも
それは覚えたいんですよね
うん あの 修行ってね 別に滝行したりとか
座禅したりすることだけじゃなくて
もう毎日ね 辛いことをしたりとか
いろんな人に会ったりとか
言葉を選んで話したりとか
それもそれは大切な修行なんでね
ありがとうございます
あとなんかあの食 食 食にこだわりすぎたりとか
あんまり執着ってよくないんですよね
そうですね  それ直したいんですけど
もう今十分直ってるよ
ありがとうございます
わかってるから大丈夫
安心してください スマサチ
スマサチの方が一番いいかもしれません
[笑い] ここは大乗仏教が取り仕切ってる場なんで
今せっかく譲られた主役の場なの
ようやく主役 ほとんど代わっていいじゃんだから
うちらとか我々が長いこと主役代わってくれるっていう話だから
ありがとうございます
そういうことで そうやすやすとちょうだい
もう話し始めるから ちょっと止まらないんだけど
またコーラテンション
だから今日は諦めてください
幸せなところ やっぱり映画のテーマなんで
どうしたらいいのか 全員がそうなるのと
誰かに妬まれて妨害されたりとか
霊術で邪とか  よくわかんないけど幸せになりますように
ありがとうございます
他には何かありませんか？ あ
こっちの方じゃあお願いしますね
座禅のことについて知りたいんですけれども
明かしください  YouTubeで座禅のお坊さんが
あの 座禅はこう リラックスポイント
それを見ながらずっと求めてるっていう話を
あの 先日動画で見たんですけども
なんてなんて？ リラックスできる姿勢を永遠と探してるっていう
それがまた座禅だっていうことをおっしゃるお坊さんがいたんですけども
その理解はそのお坊さん個人の理解なのか
それともそういうものなのか
百パーセントそう あのお坊さん自体の理解だと思う
そんな話聞いたことある？聞いたことある
ちょっとわかんない  座禅は何のために？なんか瞑想とかのとはまた違うとは思うんですけども
目的とかはあるんでしょうか
座禅 座禅のプロの方がいた
えっとね 紫舟さんと後ろの尼僧さん
もう座禅専門の方なのでね
俺ちょっとごめん 席上談義専門なんだわ
[笑い]山があるからさ
そっち専門だから ちょっと代わりに
代わりに  えーと 曹洞宗の滝沢紫舟と申します
えっと 座禅は基本的に
身  正身 定 静 息 正心じゃない？ 正身
正息 正心と言われていて
最初の身は体なんですね
まず体を整えて  調身  そうじゃないですね
それはやっぱり定身じゃなくて
整えの方ね  え ちょっとゼリーさん
まず体を整えて もうその場にいる時も体をこう
何て言うんでしょうかね
座り方とかもちゃんと説明があって
こういう風に左右対称に上下
こういう風にこう身をしっかり整えて座ってくださいというやり方がまずあるんですね
で 座り方が整ったら 次に息を
こう呼吸をして息を整えると
その後に正息 正心といって
今度は心を整える方に入るんですね
なので まず身を整えて
息を整えて その後自分の心を整えて
で えーと ずっとこう 体勢をどうするかって探してるのではなくって
やっぱり座禅をしてると
あのヴィパッサナー瞑想でもそうだと思うんですけれども
やっぱり瞑想もやってると何か絶対妄想とか出てきてしまうと思うんですが
何か出てきたらそれを
掴まないで手放すっていうことをやっぱり座禅でもするんですね
何か流れてきたら手放す
流れてきたら手放すっていうことをやるって言われてるので
体をこう求め続けるというのは
ちょっとその方独自の解釈ではないかと思います
やっぱりやってることは同じく
心を整えること 心のことをやってるっていうのは
あのヴィパッサナー瞑想も座禅も共通するところではないかなと思っております
はい  私 多分それ見たと思うんですけど
なんと  私は正直名前を出すのは控えるんですけど
よく知ってる人です [笑い]ただね
あの皆様方 座禅っていうと
まあある意味で座り方ってそんなに